hello everyone so I figured I'd do an
introduction to this video because this
the following video is gonna be pretty
much a live recording of me witness
Hubert Mosca who is the developer of SCP
secured laboratory and a few other
people that were bad at testers at the
time of us playing the game properly as
it was meant to be played my last video
it was just completely solo of me
fumbling around the game on my own this
is gonna be a lot different there's
gonna be a lot more things happening
it's a lot more entertaining to watch we
get a lot of SCP action all kinds of
stuff like that so yeah I thought it was
good to introduce at this playthrough
without further ado here we go I suppose
the class the Year Zero
yeah you can get like I think if you
just press use that most doors so
anything you can't do I think with 0 for
9 is is have an inventory they like pick
up keys and stuff I think
yeah probably I have no inventory I just
checked yeah
so I think I need to try and get to the
high containment section oh here we go
I need to get a keycard I'm scp-079 yeah
I haven't actually got past the top
floor cuz 0 7 9 spawns on the top floor
so getting dying a left or an elevator
I'm not really sure how that works yes
because I'm a disembodied AI
hmm you know what I'm just tonight well
there we go okay so I I can switch my
class so I'm a CP one seven three nine
well I can open doors as one seven three
so this that this might make it leave it
weren't you and me open the console and
type force class and then a number it's
one to ten you can do what was that okay
I guess
wait your your body completely these
bones are sorry not not not these ones
it's like you were you were a class D
but now you just look like a zombie it
was not this other round over restarting
okay okay so d do you know how to change
your class okay hello
are you recording or just playing um I
don't know can you hear us
taking on cue hello hello oh you can
hear me cool
yes we are we are trying to play right
now is this Hubert nope I don't know
what's going on I'm a MTF commander oh
so if you you know that the K to the
left of number one the tell key if you
press not to get its force class all one
word and then I think and then a
singular number
I think zero is 173 number five is zero
four nine
yeah I'm curious as to what was there
for and I can actually do you because
anytime I spawned on it azzam you just
kind of walk around really whereas like
106 is probably one of the most
interesting ones because he can actually
create sinkholes like travel through
them and stuff yeah and he can actually
walk three Doors they he doesn't need
these key cards
oh so you can survive a Tesla get but
not do like it hurts you but it doesn't
like kill you I don't actually think you
need a key card to get and two heavy
containment through cuz I think I went I
got into it without a key card okay what
what is he the could you see okay well
you sure thing come on
I I don't know I don't know I just seen
something I panicked okay yeah Hubert's
talking to me there is no SCP so you can
just you know
or bytes are you because we're in heavy
containment right hi could you open the
door please
Thanks you can take the magnetic if you
want if you got the radio you can switch
it to low range by pressing right mouse
button yeah he just told me how to use
the radios so it is cute to talk by the
way
definitely is OC you're probably quite
close to this then because we're we're
in heavy contaminate just holy about the
complete wrong way and ended up in 0-7
9s containment chamber
was that you well you look like a milky
ghost what so what does it do so it's so
this yeah I did I not turnin the you can
proceed press e on his body so uh so you
have to press e on his body there what I
just I just automatically blink whenever
you're around I kind of control when it
of that would have around here
containment chamber okay thank you
let's get away from you I'm in the
bathroom I know
I'm just playing with you I'm being yeah
I'm being stalked by I was lucky for me
are you tired are you not connected
anywhere could you repeat that
are you not connected to the game oh no
no no I will kicked out the connection
are you still here with us
yeah I'm post-class okay okay I have a
means of defense night that's good
Oh so our chances are equal
yeah by the way can I [ __ ] and kill won
7-3 yeah you kinda that's trouble you
don't have enough armor okay I don't
need to fight 911 for ya all right
why did I close the door wrong way mate
you don't have to look at me I want to
kill you I think I think you could have
killed me multiple times but I what did
you spawn us witness
let me open that
what you can open the heaven containment
yeah as if you can open the checkpoints
the model for 173 looks really cool it's
like mapping textures or something yeah
yeah yeah I'm good yeah this is standard
say there of unity oh thank you folks
you know you should kill him and me okay
let me end up okay I'm gonna be 0 for 9
just just because free it's first-class
free yeah yeah like earlier on whenever
I was playing about with the fourth
class come on I just have every class
written down beside me on my desk
just so I know which ones would you can
also type FC and for short
Oh Kersey space
so let's eat a bit go to tactic in there
come now click now you can move only for
those yeah it's just doors or if you
press the inventory button the table key
you can create a sinkhole which is
pretty cool so you can teleport back to
at any time I thought that was really
nice touch that's pretty awesome so I
can't seem to get into one of sexist
containment chamber I was 0 for 9
because you're already tried to the
tonight alpha warhead though that's the
only time I've actually tried is in the
video without time but I really didn't
know what to do
yeah I'm actually right next to a Tesla
gate so I'm just gonna stay here cuz you
said something pretty cool happens right
it's a pretty nice GFX yeah such sad
music plays at the stitch that's like
about music that says I am going to die
no hello actually work they've lights
the red lights okay
I will try to disable the alpha warheads
oh so you can actually disable it if
somebody tries yeah yeah you got the
switch in the Alpha Oracle silo
oh that's what that does okay yeah I get
it
thank you hey just let me cue you please
good luck good luck
where are you witness I almost got
zapped by the Tesla gets there oh my god
oh so do I look like a milky mom yeah
all one who sex is really cool-looking
actually use have definitely used that
different model for 106 for sure yeah
that's a different model yeah you can
actually ask if I'm just sitting here
going okay yeah okay let's see if you
know also that if you press yeah to
resurrect one terminated STP ah because
it was okay okay
I'm just gonna let the game the site for
me this time here I'm gonna be playing o
plus D that was sick I got the raw end
of the deal this time would you like to
try and micro hid on me um yeah cuz I
the first time I fired it I didn't
understand what was going on I thought
it was gonna blow up in my face it just
a single use very very I don't know
overpowered gun something like that okay
so whenever you use that on an SCP it's
like instant death almost instant okay
you can try where are you I'm at 173
containment chamber or just left okay
turn around
now type that was super creepy oh sorry
well so give 16 okay oh sweet
okay so I'll get other it's okay I can
see you a wee bit better I might need to
adjust the brightness cuz he's not there
you look like a complete shadow okay
okay
here we go
just waiting for death okay I can
imagine if if you spent all the time
like if that was a real game and he
spent all that time charging it up and
then 1:06 just went in the sinkhole
disappeared you'd be rich but there is
some kind of cool down after taking off
I don't know how to say it some kind of
cool down and then you can try to kill
him it's pretty late in Poland yeah it's
pretty late here - actually it's quarter
to 10:00 at night six nine tailed fox
commander we can just mute and try to
play normally under voice chats in the
game voice chat okay
okay so the long-range ready buddy hear
me hello hello
mmm it's very lonely up here very lonely
does anyone out there copy Arlena
hey who so what what are we doing I
haven't played this game before we
should go downstairs to the facility
okay I mean keep the person it's kind of
funny
it says he's the lieutenant that I'm the
commander and he's essentially given the
orders until I understand this game like
it will be plainer
like containments a lot of open doors
our end here
Oh Oh scientist you know
hello witness why why you just I'm gonna
put inside SC Peas
you want us to put you through the
intake or okay you have a very nice
mustache have I ever told you that
you
you need not pick it up or we have
better cards so we can escort you yeah
we can ask are you
well I can't kill anybody I got no ammo
note to self get ammo hmm he's close
there we go
having a TV - lets go get some ammo
okay
can anybody hear me hello testing
testing one two three
no need to go in find more ammunition
left no so until I find more I well I'm
just and just kind of here to send hi to
people all right this'll work right
sweet
I don't know what's going on I know it's
the radio but hey what up I'm MTF
yeah what was that
it's no oh my god that was insane
what was that
okay
hey oh hello well let's find something
get out of here man Oh nobody in here no
thank you
damn it science man nah son do you have
any or something like that
I don't care shoot me I don't care I'm
too busy for details
now some just kind of scientist are you
oh yes DP white its milk at its milky
scp-049
hello hey thanks yes it's nice it's
running straight rain rains okay
look at that zombies night containment
of Haiti containment
oh man witness er SCP Dusty's oh wait
somebody's go straight okay come on
where are you
like condemned posture thank you oh yes
I killed one nine Fox he's already a
zombie I get 60% of HP
equipment but escaped
I mean please no die you press Q with
this you press cuties we're still right
I am the researcher I think maybe this
is deadly there this is just a wild
goose chase
I'm killed the mad stomata more research
is on Kubo chick is there any way to
what your zombie I took things the the
melee attacks that zombies do seem to be
so weak it's like if you're a zero for
9-2 in this game you're essentially
Magikarp yes kind of
and wait I will open the door for him
I think weights in your day oh nine move
for one fall I'm going to open to all he
opens how does he do that he'll it
closes the door after he's this is some
it doesn't seem like it doesn't even
seem like we're actually hurt
I think I had about least 40 times
okay remote detonation a student off
North I'm a zombie Rudy North okay and
I'm gonna enter the heavy containment
zone yes okay but I'm gonna fight with
Dampier it's on me tonight
Oh Harry containment
someone died here well they did
oh yeah that's a shitload of cars a per
guy he has my five cards that he died
cause of death cause of death very many
gunshot wounds on the body okay I found
my containment chamber but I can I can
find an entrance okay I see
I think this ability for them it's just
ability sucks oh my god did you just
kill your own dude he hasn't won more
laughs does he so towards the end there
I really needed to leave so that was
that was kind of annoying the way I had
to leave the way I did but I hope this
give you a good idea of what it is like
to play this game I had an absolute
blast planet I can't wait until it
actually becomes released and steam
integration becomes a thing Hubert was
telling me it's steam integration at
this point because it's better that's we
expect really you know but whenever
steam integration comes in whenever the
full release comes like it's gonna be
class to play but you know because even
still in beta and I had quite a bit of
fun so it's ID on the 20th of December I
won't actually be around on that date
unfortunately I will be away seeing my
family but whenever I come back I'm
gonna be organized in a playthrough with
my $10 plus patrons cheaper it is
informed me that each game you can have
up to 20 people a server so that's
pretty good so I'm really looking
forward to organizing some like secret
laboratory events that's something I
really want to do so again if you've
made it this far thank you very much for
watching please consider getting the
game I'm not being paid
by anybody to say this I just really
like the [ __ ] thanks very much for
listening and I'll see you all soon bye
bye
you